este problema dice lo siguiente los
números de ramas de un roble y de un
abedul desde 1950 se representan con las
siguientes tablas y aquí las tengo la
tabla del roble que si te das cuenta
tenemos el tiempo en años y en un
principio cuando estábamos en 1950 y no
había pasado ningún año se midió que
tenía 34 ramas después de que pasaron
tres años tenía 46 ramas después de que
pasaron 6 años tenía 59 ramas y así
sigue y sigue y sigue y por su parte
tenemos al ave dhul y si observas bien
vas a ver que pasa algo similar con el
abedul un registro inicial dice que
tenía ocho ramas después de que pasan
diez años tiene 33 ramas y así seguimos
y bueno lo que quiero que encontremos en
este vídeo es que modelo quedaría
bastante bien para representar el número
de ramas con respecto al tiempo del
roble y del abedul aunque realmente este
ejercicio y eso nos va a ayudar un poco
viene en una sección donde se comparan
los modelos lineales con los modelos
exponenciales déjame escribirlo de un
modelo lineal lineal
contra un modelo exponencial contra un
modelo exponencial así que que nos
quedaría mejor para modelar el número de
ramas de un roble y de un abedul un
modelo lineal o un modelo exponencial y
bueno qué te parece si empezamos con el
roble y se observa la clave aquí es que
estamos aumentando en tres después
aumentamos también en tres después
aumentamos también en tres y después
aumentamos también en tres así que nos
vamos a fijar en el número de ramas y
vamos a ver si el cambio cada tres años
es un cambio fijo o cercano a un cambio
fijo y si es así bueno un modelo lineal
quedaría bastante bien o en su dado caso
que tengamos un cambio que dependa del
tiempo en el que estamos así que si te
preguntas de qué estoy hablando vamos a
ver lo que pasa de 34 46 bueno pues si
observas de 34 46 hemos crecido 2
unidades es decir tenemos 12 ramas más
bien que pasas de 46 a 59
bueno pues si observas de 46 59
aumentamos 3 en este caso muy bien de 59
a 70 en esta ocasión aumentamos 11
aumentamos 11 y de 70 82 aumentamos 12 y
bueno lo que quiero que observes ahorita
es que no tenemos un cambio fijo
constante pero tenemos aproximadamente
un cambio fijo constante si observas
nuestro cambio fijo constante sería
aproximadamente de 12 y es que recuerda
que este es un modelo en la vida real no
siempre tenemos un cambio constante
los modelos lo que nos dan es una buena
aproximación un buen ajuste en este caso
no sé al comportamiento del número de
ramas que tiene un roble con respecto al
tiempo para mí esto se ve como una muy
buena aproximación a un aumento de 12
ramas cada tres años
así que con esto sería muy bueno que
construyera mi modelo lineal y voy a
decir que el número de ramas lo voy a
poner así que depende del tiempo que
está dado en años va a ser igual a quién
y ojo observa que aumenta 12 ramas
aproximadamente cada tres años como
puedo escribir este modelo lineal bueno
pues el ddt va a ser igual y primero nos
vamos a aplicar en el número de ramas
inicial en el tiempo de igual a cero en
el tiempo de igual a cero empezamos con
34 ramas así que lo voy a poner x 34
ramas y después cada año que pase
cuantas ramas le vamos a agregar bueno
pues pienso de la siguiente manera si
cada tres años aumentamos doce ramas eso
quiere decir que en promedio cada año
aumentamos cuatro ramas
por lo tanto cuatro por t y este base de
mi modelo lineal y lo podemos comprobar
cuánto va a ser r de cero cuando han
pasado 0 años
bueno pues esto se cancela
solamente me quedo con 34 y si tomamos
el otro punto extremo
supongamos este en cuanto es r r de 12
vamos a ver si llegamos a una buena
aproximación esto va a ser lo mismo que
34 más 4 por 12 es 48 y si sumamos estos
dos me dan 82 entonces este es un modelo
que aproxima bastante bien el número de
ramas que vamos a tener en nuestro roble
dependiendo del tiempo tal vez no sea el
número exacto pero va a ser una buena
aproximación y por lo tanto vamos a
decir que este es un modelo lineal de
lujo ya acabamos con el roble ahora
vamos a fijarnos en el abedul bueno lo
primero que sería bueno revisar sería el
cambio en el tiempo si observas el
cambio en el tiempo es de 10 años cada
vez que se recopilan datos de
de cada ok ahora vamos a fijarnos en el
cambio que tenemos en el número de ramas
y se observa en un principio del año
1950 a 1960 cambiamos de 833 es decir
tenemos un cambio de 25 ramas muy bien y
nuestra siguiente medición después de 10
años es de 128 así que en este caso
estamos cambiando estamos cambiando algo
más de 25 de eso sí estoy seguro pero
cuánto es
bueno 8 13 595 95 ramas muy bien y por
lo tanto puedes ver aquí que claramente
este no es un modelo lineal así que qué
te parece si mejor lo pensamos en
términos de un modelo exponencial y para
eso no me voy a tomar la suma vamos a
buscar porque el número estoy
multiplicando para llegar al siguiente
bueno nuestro cambio en el número de
años es siempre de 10 años y en el
número de ramas si pasamos de 8 a 33
porque tuvimos que multiplicar 8 para
llegar a 33 bueno aproximadamente
tuvimos que multiplicar por 4 8 por 4 32
así que no nos compliquemos la vida y
voy a decir que es aproximadamente 4 y
de 33 a 128 bueno pasa lo mismo estoy
multiplicando aproximadamente por 4 no
es 4 como tal porque 4 por 33 es lo
mismo que 132
es aproximadamente 4 y de 128 para 512
bueno al 128 en esta ocasión si lo estoy
multiplicando por cuatro por cuatro
exacto porque 4 por 120 es 480 32 es 512
así que ya empieza a tomar esto un poco
de sentido podemos verlo como un modelo
exponencial voy a decir que
aproximadamente estamos multiplicando
por cuatro cada diez años y esa va a ser
nuestra buena aproximación así que
podemos decir que en esta ocasión el dt
en rd te va a ser igual a quien bueno
primero fijémonos en nuestro número de
ramas inicial que es 8 lo voy a poner
aquí ya este 8 lo vamos a multiplicar
por nuestra razón común que es 4 que es
4 y hay que tener cuidado porque a este
4 a qué expresión lo vamos a elevar
bueno pues si lo que queremos es saber
cuánto va a crecer por año lo que vamos
a hacer es él
4 a la potencia de sobre 10 y esto es
porque cada 10 años vamos a multiplicar
por 4 si te vale 10 entonces vamos a
multiplicar una vez por 4 si te vale 20
entonces vamos a multiplicar dos veces
por 4 y así sucesivamente y aquí ya lo
tienes tenemos un buen modelo que
aproxima al número de ramas del abedul
inclusive lo puedes comprobar no sé con
algún dato
imagínate que nos tomamos el red de 30 y
bueno tienes ere de 30 después de 30
años me va a quedar en mi modelo 8 por 4
elevado a la 30 entre 10 lo cual es 3
entonces me quedarían 8 que multiplica a
4 al cubo que es lo mismo que 8 por 4 el
cubo que es 64 muy bien 8 por 64 y esto
es lo mismo que bueno 6 por 8 48 más 32
es 512
512 y si observas estamos bien en este
caso salió el número exacto o podríamos
tener una buena aproximación así que es
buen momento para decir que el número de
ramas del abedul se puede modelar bien
con un modelo exponencial y ya están
tenemos una buena aproximación y un buen
trabajo también para las ramas del
abedul